on se dirige en fait vers
une des
chambres de cet étage
présidentiel une plongée dans le temps
et dans l'histoire du château de
Rambouillet après un an de travail de
reconstitution avec le Mobilier national
le site a retrouvé son style des années
50 Vincent auiol est alors président de
la République après la guerre il a une
ambition faire de rouiller une vitrine
des arts décoratifs français la plus
grande spécificité c'est cette volonté
de redonner vie à l'ensemble des Arts
Décoratifs français à la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale vous êtes ici
dans un palais dans un château
présidentiel et le président Vincent
Riol a voulu mettre en avant la
décoration chose rare pour l'époque la
présidence va faire appel à de nombreux
décorateurs mais aussi des décoratrices
cette chambre donc a été
décoré par Suzanne guigichon nous sommes
dans ce qui est la chambre de Paul Oriol
qui était fils de Michel et Vincent rol
le président dans cette chambre avec vue
un mobilier contemporain où le luxe à la
française est représenté toutes ces
caractéristiques vous les trouvez
également aussi bien pour lestable de
chevet le lit avec ces immenses plages
donc de parchemin tout au long de la
visite une enfilade de pièces h style
unique et où le temps semble s'être
arrêté parmi elle l'appartement des
chefs d'État étrangers ù de nombreuses
personnalités ont séjourné comme un
certain Nelson Mandela en
1996 aujourd'hui le palais n'est plus
présidentiel mais il continue de se
réinventer avec cette exposition
exceptionnelle l'objectif est de refaire
vivre l'histoire du lieu c'est c'est
vraiment la période pour ambouillet qui
a été la plus fertile en matière de
création en matière d'art décoratif
parce que c'était un véritable chantier
qui s'est déroulé ici de même qu'à
l'Élysée d'ailleurs puisque les Orioles
ont voulu faire des résidences
présidentielles les vitrines des
savoir-fa Français en matière d'art
décoratif donc c'est vraiment les plus
grands décorateurs on dirait aujourd'hui
designers qui ont travaillé pour le
couple Oriol et qui ont déessé des
pièces magistrales pour ambouillet si
certaines pièces seront restituées à la
fin de l'exposition le château continue
à écrire une nouvelle page de son
histoire avec le réameublement d'autres
pièces dans les années à
venir